bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce matin sur arte france donc on
a appris que la police avait tué des
dizaines de manifestants à almaty il ya
aussi d une dizaine de morts côté force
de l'ordre ces manifestants ont tenté de
s'emparer de bâtiments publics comment
est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là au
kazakhstan
les côtés ça a été très rapide
effectivement ça a été dit dans votre
sujet ces parties de la région de
l'ouest pétroliers du kazakhstan où il y
a eu lie il y a dix ans une très grande
révolte suite à un an de grève des
travailleurs des usines de pétrole donc
c'est
ça pouvait de toute façon dans cette
région qui se sent délaissée et
productrice aux fins détentrice d du
pétrole mais ne profitant pas de la
manne pétrolière et
le gouvernement a immédiatement
accepté de baisser les prix dans cette
région du gaz du gaz liquide qui est
utilisé pour les voitures des de la
plupart delà des gens et
est du coup les autres bons de le reste
de la population du kazakhstan qui
souffre énormément de la crise
économique comme ça a été dit depuis des
années et notamment depuis les deux ans
de provident ça s'est répandue comme une
traînée de poudre voilà donc
c'est pas du tout une
c'est pas du tout une nouvelle qui nous
étonne mais par contre la rapidité et la
violence qui en a découlé ça par contre
ça pose question et sur la crise
économique il faut l'imputé uniquement à
la crise sanitaire
non pas seulement la crise économique ça
fait en réalité le kazakhstan paie le
prix de d'avoir tout misé sur le pétrole
depuis des années est en crise depuis
depuis 2008 donc la crise mondiale il ya
2 des dévaluations successives de la
monnaie nationale et donc le prix des
denrées alimentaires
c'est à grimper l'inflation
depuis depuis le moment du coup vite sa
résidence mais c'est sa durée depuis un
certain temps que toute façon alors le
président kazakhstanais a demandé l'aide
de la russie et de ses alliés qui ont
envoyé des troupes un ses troupes c'est
leçon de maintien de la paix y sont
arrivés ce matin au kazakhstan est ce
que cela peut calmer la situation les
tensions
l'écouté d'après les personnes que j'ai
réussi à joindre mes collègues de
d'almaty ils sont catastrophés les
kazakhes donc ils considèrent que c'est
une atteinte à l'honneur de leur pays de
leurs polices même deux pas de là leur
armée de ne pas avoir compté sur les
propres forces pour que si rapidement en
appeler à l'organisation du traité de
sécurité collective qui d'ailleurs n'a
pas bougé au moment de du de l'arménie
et du karabagh
donc ils sont extrêmement choqués et ils
sont très inquiets il pense qu'il va y
avoir des victimes maintenant
voilà assez
c'est une mauvaise chose pour eux
d'avoir fait appel si rapidement à cette
organisation
enfin ses troupes de maintien de la paix
le haut niveau de leurs prérogatives
justement est-ce qu'elles ont pour
mission d'intervenir vous pensez de de
jouer les médiateurs d'intervenir au
sein de des affrontements qui peuvent
avoir entre les forces de l'ordre et les
manifestants
écoutez elles sont l son maintien de la
paix c'est leur nom les appels casques
bleus il les appelle casques bleus mais
en réalité liées à dire à un om dans ce
mouvement social qui au départ est un
mouvement social comme dans beaucoup de
pays du monde et qui à un moment donné
dérape dans la violence dans une
violence inouïe avec des manifestants
qui ce qu'ils sont effectivement armée
et sa pause ça pose une question il ya
toujours une hypothèse on se demande
toujours qui est derrière et pourquoi
c'est comme ça et c'est ce que c'est ce
que les observateurs se disent aussi les
casaques qui observe la situation ils se
disent mais qu'est-ce-qui sans réalité
est ce que est ce que cette videmment
que cette force ii n'a pas pour mission
de
d'envenimer la situation mais au
contraire de la calmer le plus
rapidement possible mais le fait
d'amener des hommes armés
venus de dpi et notamment de la russie
c'est extrêmement mal pris part de
nombreux segments de la population
notamment la partie nationale a list les
intellectuels ça ne va pas forcément
arranger disons le peut-être calmer le
jeu
donc tu es tellement sur le fond de
quand même une très grande défiance
envers notamment l'ancien président il
ya vraiment une rancoeur qui s'exprime
hélas les forces de sécurité collective
ne peuvent rien faire contre ce qu'il ya
au fond du coeur de des casaques juste
une dernière question le président du
kazakhstan a pris plusieurs décisions
dont justement le remplacement du lac ce
chef de l'état noursoultan nazarbaïev à
la tête du conseil de sécurité ce
conseil de sécurité il était on sait
qu'il était au centre du pouvoir quel
est le sens et l'impact de cette
décision
cette décision elle est accompagnée de
la démission complète du gouvernement ce
qui est une première depuis
l'indépendance du kazakhstan depuis 30
ans
c'est aussi l'occasion de faire
démissionner tout l'entourage de
nazarbaïev fuck qui constituaient les
ministres et les principaux chefs de la
sécurité de du kazakhstan donc on
pourrait y voir peut-être une prise
d'indépendance du président tokayev si
toutefois il réussit à ramener l'ordre
dans son pays et si il réussit à faire
passer la pilule d'avoir demandé si tôt
l'intervention 2e
des sodas de l'organisation du traité de
sécurité collective
donc ça pourrait être vu c'est une
hypothèse comme une façon de se
débarrasser du double pouvoir de cette
transition qui n'en était pas tout à
fait une où il était président mais il y
avait le président sortant qui gardaient
la main sur sur beaucoup de deux centres
du pouvoir et de centres économiques du
pays donc est ce que c'est un mot rien
est ce qu'une chance est ce que c'est
une chance et qu'il saura la saisir est
ce qu'il va pouvoir dialoguer avec la
population est ce que la population va
lui faire confiance c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne peut pas prévoir
c'est une hypothèse que je vous soumets
mais ça ça m'a fait penser à ça le fait
de deux qui se soit débarrassé de tout
cet entourage c'est peut-être
l'indépendance réelle de son pouvoir à
lui en tant que président du pays seuls
détenteurs de mercy mercy avoue
catherine poujol je rappelle que vous
êtes l'ancienne directrice de l'institut
français d'études sur l'asie centrale et
professeur à l'inalco